uh what does a successful micro school
teachers business look like do they have
10 students at 10k each or 20k each do
they
make twice as much as they did when they
were teacher 25 more
is it the same but they get more control
what does it look like
scale we have the most data around child
care so between the ages of zero and
five
sure and uh you know what we've seen on
the ch
from a childcare perspective because
we're all over the country so our
average is
you know can they're they're all over
the place but roughly you can go from
about thirty thousand dollars a year
to seventy thousand dollars a year
yeah a little bit more than double yeah
creating but you know we have providers
who are making who can make 150 000
a year running a child care program
i've talked to when we you know when we
launched our micro school
solution i've started to build
relationships with um
existing micro school providers all over
the country to learn more about sort of
their businesses and
i've talked to folks who are making you
know 200 000
a year running micro schools um
in clearly affluent areas um
but uh but there's a lot more upside
that you you have
you have access to running a uh
a micro school what i love about what
you're doing is you actually have the
pricing on the site so i just did a
search on wunderschool for my zip code
and looking around the peninsula of the
bay area
you can see different micro schools from
you know a thousand to two thousand a
month i'm sure that depends on how many
hours your kids are in and i'm sure
there
are you know eight kids but they all
make a profile a beautiful profile where
you see the program director
uh and they've been background checked
what days the ratio one to three
providers to children what a great ratio
yeah so you've really dialed this in and
answered all the questions people would
have and then you even have a great
section chris
on the site when you're looking at these
profiles of the rhythm of the day
7 30 to 8 30 drop off breakfast clean up
diaper change circle time art snack
outdoor time
dancing time dramatic play free time you
get the idea nap time pick up time
and then you even have the calendar
there and admissions and how to
apply and to take a tour you just
basically take all that friction out
it really is like looking at an airbnb
um and i'm sure that was part of the
inspiration yes that's exactly right and
that's the key
as a consumer right as a as a parent
these are things that you expect to see
when you're looking for a school when
you're an educator these are things that
are very
foreign to you you know um it's very
common to find that most schools don't
list their price
you have to fi you have to work so hard
to get the price but
this is these are these are decisions
that we all use when we're making
decisions
so we try to surface all the things a
parent needs
to be able to make a decision and we try
to be as transparent as possible
so that the parent can make the best
choice for them because the other
interesting thing about
child care in school it's sort of like
buying a home
you me and you know we took a sample
size of 10 of your listeners
we all have different ideas on where we
want to live we have different ideas on
the types of homes we want
we have different ideas around the type
of schooling that we would put our
children in
there's a lot more variables that go
into making that decision than
the average decision i think this is
that's a super important point uh chris
because
parents for some reason seem to have
abdicated
their childhood education to the public
school system
without even thinking or considering
other possibilities and this
this pandemic i think one of the silver
linings to it is that you can sit for a
second and pause when your kids are home
yeah hey what do i want my kids
education to look like
what are the possibilities totally
because homeschooling you felt weird
right like felt like a weird thing to
homeschool yeah then you start thinking
about like why i'm homeschooling and
yeah what else could this look like what
would it look like if i had a tutor come
in twice a week or
an actual teacher come in half the time
or whatever yeah when we started the
company we're like hey
let's make them all montessori schools
right montessori is the best
and then we started talking to parents
and that's that's that's just my idea of
what's the best every every parent has
it really
but it really is the best i'll just be
honest because we're in montessori
why explain what montessori is and would
you did you go to a montessori school
when you're a kid i didn't i didn't go
to a monster
with montessori why did you go into i
went to a stem school
and and uh that seemed to have turned
out all right
yeah yeah yeah company the marketplace
it worked out it worked i think your
parents are pretty happy right now
yeah you are you're bold and you build
the future i like it